today we're gonna jump right in because
if you're a cool last time I blew your
little bringing depart by showing you
that this is up your dad this sophia has
all this factorial stuff happening
unbeaten and now we need a crazy by help
us understand from the pattern that
before and I'm going to keep doing a sec
but we want to roll and what are the
actual questions we're going to happen
how do you take advantage of what you do
to answer questions like this so have a
look at them agree well video is more
there is our licensed diplomat new
miracle but as I put it down even those
things that you with real numbers can be
dealt with by your calculator you need
to affect your muscles of manipulating
things go with a solid subjunctive when
your calculator is useless you can take
it off okay so 85 143 we want to start
to get a little familiar with the actual
factorial definition for some of the
dudes just up here on the yard line is
under bored maybe you want to do this on
a fresh page like a pretty good movie
news I want you to remember the NCR is
equal to all right infraction what are
the tops and the story for the one is to
another are that guru and one of our
spectrum until you remember this term is
easy to identify to be some boxes and
then these guys add up to that big nose
so let's the eight factorial to top it
might be two factorial dictatorial one
or five three or four four or whatever
the people of how far along you are so
if you've got that in your boy it may be
rid of their to cook for yourself let's
have a go and substituting into what all
these numbers are for Exeter hd5 you yes
on the top is going to be a [ __ ] lauriol
and all the denominator
you look at yourself own right that's
one of those at the other one will be
great now because the turtle delivered
is some fraction I'm just going to avoid
20 fractured bone fractures you can do
it it's nothing wrong with it I just
feel like your options to confuse
yourself so I'm just going to write /
and then I'm going to do the next one 14
so again on the top 4 factorial divided
by 3 factorial 1 factorial and even
though 1 factorial doesn't change what
it is we're to write it anyway because
it's part of what NCR me all right I'm
just on the substitutes now it's time to
supply out I'm going to do get with the
fractions first I do to multiplying turn
a five-county so that leaves me with 8
factorial 3 factorial on the numerator
and 5 factorial 4 factorial 3 center or
the facilitator and you tear that like I
haven't done any canceling I just put
everything in the right people and now
I'm ready to go okay careful for the 3
factorial neighbors gone okay you can
see part of the eight factorial can be
careful that what's up in the
denominator what's the biggest thing is
get the fine print so you say you little
silly traced by the tidings got rid of
the five factorial what you're left with
is 8 times 7 times 6 yes and you can
write the full unrolled versions but
then you can get 5x over here you've
already got a slice my turn on the
bottom so if you're feeling a
comfortable distance just write it like
I see where you came from now you cancel
it free now this by factorial god these
three centuries also
I'm sorry righteous out long hair and
just why so I can duplicate for me right
you can see the fortitude easier they're
going to get rid of the eight there
anything else I can do yeah this three
two kids last pot of the peaks what's
left of this is ok up would you mm just
just one ok that ain't gon the sentence
kill man this is turned into our place
to which means that's what else you
gonna like I said yes your calculator
could have done that from the beginning
but not when it's algebra like it this
is it with we're not seen this kind of
question before you can solve it
logically is in the patterns of Europe
or you can appeal to this factorial
definition of the entity Armitage so I'm
going to do that the second way each of
these can be written it is for right so
imagine wonderful exercise of reconcile
so that's it going to be impactful on
one living forces if I turned out on
three factorial times my environment and
midas three magical are astray turn in
my dream I don't like a fun
by the same token the right hand side is
easy in terms of positional now this
relation to keep it Estep stated like
the ebc that i can see is i decide to
cancel some things out agree so it's
obviously look obviously designed by
side by looks like a factorial Lacey's
be identically on the people relapse the
book so both of those are going to
vanish away a good is there anything
else I can really easily see that i can
let me do with the compass book okay
this is 3 times 2 times 1 this is
sometimes on so this is going to go
leaving me with just three over here
okay all right I could do some awesome
stuff like Brady sign get books on the
right now okay I've got one left on top
we said the part of this 3 factorial is
going to go which is going to leave us
with that and then this concern until
one the whole 2 factorial disappear and
now I have that so far so good yes so
I'm not bitter yet obviously please let
us keep going a little bit since I've
got one over something whatever
something never the same I can actually
just take reciprocal of cosine it's not
inequality it's an equation that all
would once I hit that our heart is and
it I've got two factorials which are
clearly related so I'm going to do that
unrolling thing you do right when you
are all factorial zone after very
careful see you here remember this one
min editorial you are role-based because
it's the bigger one right and it
includes 5 factorial inner which what
let you cancel out ok wouldn't it be
much point to unroll the 5 factorial
because then which part of a factor will
do is get
so here I need to know which one of
these factorials is bigger now 3 is a
bigger number than two but n minus 3
factorial is not bigger than n minus 2
capsules why is that
ok
what week to fudge and pictorial
language hit it with n times n minus 1
times n minus 2 and so on right down to
three and then two and then one now if
you start from n minus three right if
you start to that what's the next term
minus 4 that's a smaller number is Sir
and then the next one will be n minus 5
so those are all the way to 3 times 2 to
1 agree so you can see in my link to in
a smaller this is um it's bigger it's
this one over here so this is a larger
term it has more term dinner even though
the number seems smaller yes doesn't I
liked it n minus 3 in my computer
monster monster for what journey by the
middle of the line but life if you like
pina unlike tackle triangular like it
doesn't have this don't have to be there
so you're talking about the sign of
which turns on Patrick triangles in a
row I want in but that's what we're
talking about here but now i can't all
this stuff out and it is no longer
talking about parking pass the triangle
it's just too immense factorial right
cosmic items made up of factorials is
made up of a particular combination and
we've put blow that up or you'll be on
campuses so here's what I'm going to do
I don't know two things first I'm gonna
take reciprocal the first line that
leads me we did on the top on the left
hand side now the right hand side that
was a huge n minus 2 factorial but i'm
going to unroll it just achieve it
that's the next turn right and then all
the rest on till three in the tool in
one that makes it so this makes clear
now what I need to cancel this needs to
go and you
sir n minus 2 Z 3 yes in ministry 33 35
from here he'll yes I divided respond by
n factorial because it was a common
factor if it's the same on both sides
and isolated everybody just like if I
had if I was holding in a crazy in my
forest equals 100 I would divide reside
by a colored back down a ways oh and so
i divide through giving me that well
I've done exactly to say to you it's
just a thing I was dividing through by
before it was in factoria yes yes have a
look what your sexual is gone why is it
going you remember why it went so
standard 3 factorial here and choose a
tortilla right we'll remember what each
of these short nipple right this is 3
times 2 times 1 and this is 2 times 1
well I don't need to do that twice I got
rid of two times one that's why this is
just the three and notice three couture
listen yes it like
like you restriction right when you
reciprocate 22 you enter okay so i'll
come back to restrictions later on
insulting this whole thing is restricted
because in Pascal's triangle as what in
the-- annotations and to only be 0 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 but natural numbers right you
can't have fractions you can't have
negative lots of things you can't have
so there's already a lot in addition to
place right even up here those
restrictions are just mentioned 0 1 2 3
4 5 this still in place here actually
haven't really been you for example in
it kpr there's nothing you can put in
the eye but the 50-50 rules here on to
determine there's nothing you can put
Nikki to make either these denominators
viewer you know that buggy included it
equal to this is extreme item 2 0
factorial the 0 factorial is not viewer
is one leading / that that's fine so
therefore that is actually ok and this
fiscal rules that we had the ball over
um we have a vanilla we're done but just
before you move on to this last one
which will trigger to an art form do you
see what this means what role has two
triangle my arm right on fine right well
that means that 5t three and five be two
are the same well that makes sense
positive because on the street road the
second is third terms are there in the
middle i think that was tense yeah okay
so therefore that's what this means i
hit number n just like some number hey
nap until know where it says something
about what you originally thinking about
which role Pascal triangle on the
secular terms identical as up
design